الى انقره حيث افاده وزاره الدفاع التركيه
ان وزير الدفاع خلال تفقد الوحدات
العسكريه المنتشره قرب الحدود مع سوريا في
انطاكيا اعتذارك بعد ساعات من تاكيده ان
بلاده لا تهدد سياده الدول الجاره وانها
تستهدف العناصر الارهابيه فحسب وفق تعبيره
معنا من انقره مراسله الجزيره فرح الزمان
شوقي فرح ما دلاله هذه الزياره
رمزيه لا سيما انها تاتي بعد يوم واحد من
التصريحات التي صدرت عن وزير الدفاع نفسه
والتي اكد فيها بان العمل مستمر على
الطاوله وفي الميدان في ان الواحد يخرج
وزير الدفاع التركي اليوم برفقتي رئيس
هيئه الاركان وقاده القوات البريه
والبحريه والجويه ليتفقد وحدات تركيا
عسكريه على الحدود مع سوريا في محاوله
لتاكيد على مساله الجهوزيه او لتوجيه همم
الرسائل في الوقت الذي يبدو ان تركيا تقضي
فيه وقت المستقبل بعد كل التصعيد الذي جرى
وحول وبعد كل الحديث الذي دار عن احتمال
عمليه عسكريه في الشمال السوري وزيره
الدفاع التركي يوم امس كان قد قدم تقيما
سنويا لابرز القضايا الامنيه
والعسكريه المتعلقه بالداخل التركي وبعد
القضايا الاقليميه الدوليه كان واضح سئل
من قبل بعض الصحفيين عن مساله مصير
العمليه العسكريه البريه في شمال سوريا
وعن مدى صحه الانباء التي تقول بان تركيا
تتفاوض مع روسيا حول مساله منحها غطاء جوي
لشن ضربات جويه يقول هنا وزير الدفاع
العمل مستمر في الميدان وعلى الطاوله في
اشاره منه الى الحوار عبر الوسيط الروسي
لتحقيق المطالب والشروط التركيه المتمثله
بخروج الوحدات الكرديه من تل رفعت من عين
العرب من منبج الى جانب ابعاد التهديدات
التي تعتبرها تركيا تهديدات امنيه عن
شريطها الحدود الجنوبي بمسافه 30 كيلو متر
وزير الدفاع قبل ان يلتقي الصحفيين كان قد
عقد مؤتمرا ادلى فيه بتصريحات اكد فيها
بان تركيا لا تهدد الدول الجاره لكن لا
يجب ان يتوقع احد بانها ستكون متسامحه
بمعنى ان تركيا في هذه الفتره تبقى في خط
الوسط تشون ضربات عسكريه بين الحين والاخر
يتحدث عن تحيد ما يقارب 4000 عنصر من هذه
الوحدات سواء في تركيا في شمال سوريا شمال
العراق ولكن هذه الحصيله منذ بدايه العام
الجاري لكن في الوقت الراهن يبدو ان تركيا
تنتظر نتائج همم التفاوض نتائج الرد على
الشروط التي كانت قد اعلنتها لروسيا في
وقت سابق بين الحين والاخر تقوم بتنفيذ
عمليات امنيه اا بشكل الرئيس تقوم
باعتقالات وتقول بانها تقوم بتحيد بعض
العناصر التي تصنفها عناصر ارهابيه من قبل
الوحدات الكرديه وحزب العمال الكردستاني
من جهتها قالت وسائل الاعلام مقربه مما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه ان الجيش
التركي قصف بقذائف المدفعيه مواقع في رفع
عفرين ورفعين العرب بريف حلب وموقعه في
ريفيتال الابيض بريف الرقه واضافتنا الجيش
التركي قصف ايضا ووقع في قريتين في ناحيه
الزركان والاسديه بريف الحسكه